In this unit you'll cover videos
from a couple different courses.
You'll look at some videos from
Sebastian Rune's Introduction to
Machine Learning course,
produced here at Udacity.
And you'll also look at some videos from
Georgia Tech's Machine Learning course
with Charles Isabelle and
Michael Litman.
Along the way you'll cover several
methods for doing supervised learning
like neural networks, ensemble learning,
regression, classification.
These are different ways of
approaching supervised learning.
One of the main learning goals here is
to be able to evaluate those different
methods and test whether or
not they're the best idea for
a certain incoming data set.
And so those are really the two
dual learning goals for this unit.
We want you to understand how to apply
these methods, but we also want you to
understand how to evaluate when
you should apply each method.